How was your weekend, Sally?
I had a really good time last weekend.
My dad took me to the amusement park.
Did you ride a merry-go-round there?
Yes, I did.
It was fun.
Did you ride a roller coaster, too?
No, I didn't ride a roller coaster.
Why not?
It is really exciting!
When my family is sick, Doctor Jen makes us feel better.
My sisters have a fever.
Let's take them to Doctor Jen.
My father has a cough.
Let's take him to Doctor Jen.
My mother has a sore throat.
Let's take her to Doctor Jen.
My grandpa has stiff knees.
Let's take him to Doctor Jen.
My grandma has an earache.
Let's take her to Doctor Jen.
My dog has a sore paw.
We can't take him to Doctor Jen.
Let's take him to the vet!